Cyber security is one of the fastest
growing and most respected fields today
and earning your CIS certification can
open the door to some of the highest
paying and most trusted roles in the
industry. But passing the SIS isn't just
about memorizing facts. It's about
understanding how to think like a
security leader. That's exactly what
this course is designed to do. I will
walk you through every domain, simplify
complex topics and share real world
example that will help you not only pass
the exam but truly master cyber
security. So before we begin, like this
video, hit that subscribe button and
turn on the notification bell.
Welcome to the domain number seven,
security operations. This domain carries
a weightage of 13%. This is a huge
demand. So grab a cup of coffee and
let's get started.
An introduction to security operations.
So security operations focuses on
maintaining and monitoring security
controls across people, processes and
technology. So we have applied different
controls security controls for example
technology we may have firewalls we may
have other controls like let's suppose
encryption for data at rest for
processes we may have let's suppose
policies
and similarly for people we may also
have applied different policies such as
separation of duties background check
etc.
So security operations deal with
maintaining and monitoring these
controls so that they are acting as
required. So it ensures that controls
remain functional and effective against
organizational risk. So control are
apply against the threat and risk posed
to the organization.
So continuous separation means that we
need to ensure that these controls are
working and they are effective or they
are working in an effective manner.
So these involves first the risk
identification then assessment and then
application of mitigation in form of
these controls. So continuously uh when
we apply controls it doesn't mean that
we are done with the security. So during
operations we also identify new risk we
assess them and then again we apply
mitigation through these controls.
So all these processes involves or
include coordination across areas like
physical security incident response and
investigation and digital presence. So
we will study all these in detail in the
upcoming slides.
So these are the core objectives of
security operation. First one is the
operational continuity which ensures
security uh supports business with
minimal disruption or cost. So we will
study the DR processes the DR and BCP
disaster recovery and business
continuity. So these are the processes
that supports business with minimal
disruption or cost. This mitigation
apply and monitor security control based
on the identified threat. Accountability
is that security function ensures
control are applied correctly even for
areas managed by others. So it doesn't
mean that you just apply the control
making sure that the controls are
applying applied correctly to the
correct in the correct areas and they
are acting or functioning as per the
requirements is the uh accountability of
these control. Then we have the asset
protection which is to maintain
inventory and protection strategy for
all critical assets.
So our first topic in overall security
operation is the investigations inside
an organization. So investigations
follows from security incidents. For
example, the incident may be some
criminal policy violation or outages.
So security practitioners often support
but don't directly conduct
investigation. So the investigation is
uh most often conducted by specialist
for forensic team. But the security puh
practitioners such as CISP they support
these investigation.
So the security practitioners must
coordinate with digital forensics and
legis experts to conduct these
investigation. Incorrect evidence
handling can destroy its value inside
the court.
So evidence collection and handling and
the steps include to record everything
that is to document the actions, the
timestamps and the people involved. So
what action were performed, when they
were performed and who performed these
action. You know uh we need to record
everything during evidence collection.
Use copy copies only. Another important
uh factor and consideration that is to
perform analysis on bit level copies not
original. So do not uh important thing
is to not perform investigation on the
original documents or original hard
drives or other data but rather to make
bit level copies and perform analysis of
those copies. Preserve integrity. So to
use right blockers which uh functions by
uh blocking the right access to these
let's suppose digital media media such
as it may be flash drive, hard drives or
other digital uh artifacts hash value to
use hash value so that we know that the
integrity of the data is preserved and
prevent data alteration and avoid
destructive action. So do not power off
the systems and isolate the system
instead. If you power off the system, it
means that the data in the RAM, the
temporary data, it may be lost. So we do
not need uh we uh don't have to power
off the system rather than we have to
isolate the system from other system and
the network.
What is chain of custody? So chain of
custody maintains evidence integrity and
authenticity during transfer or handling
of the evidence. So it proves that the
evidence remained under controlled
conditions. It uses ISO 2703720
and NIST SP800-86
for best practices. So these two uh
framework provide best practices for the
chain of custody.
in of custody is important for code
admissibility and legal compliance.
So what are some forensic challenges
inside the cloud? So cloud data is
replicated globally making location and
jurisdiction complex. So the cloud
provider replicate data due to
redundancy and other factors globally.
That's why uh making the location and
the juris jurisdiction of data during
forensic a challenging task. So some
cloud provider uh cloud service provider
may restrict access to forensic data due
to their own policies. So sis must
ensure that the contracts and policies
support forensic access. So during uh
contract with the CSPs it is a task of
the SIS to ensure that it is included in
the contract that the data can be
accessed for forensic analysis if
required. So balance between business
needs and legal application. We need to
have uh the balance between our business
requirements as well as the legal
application due to different laws and
regulation.
So reporting and documentation as we
said that we need to record every step
that is the detection of the incident
evidence gathered then investigation and
finally the outcome.
So it also include the metadata which
includes who, when and how the evidence
was collected. Documentation supports
chain of custody as well as the
accountability.
And the finally the report must in must
be accurate, authentic, comprehensible,
convincing, adjective and admissible. So
report must have these qualities in
order for it to be admissible inside
court or to other uh you can say legal
authorities.
So these are some of the investigation
or investigative techniques. So the
techniques include data capture and it
can be done through logs, capturing the
traffic,
video surveillance of the uh you can say
data or the processes and these all may
be either automated or manual. Then the
interviews
from the employees are user inside the
organization where the incident took
place.
to interview includes to question the
witnesses and it must follow legal
rights of the witnesses.
Interrogation which is performed mainly
by law enforcement on the suspects and
external requests or legal processes
like subpoenas or warrants.
What are some digital forensic tools,
tactics and procedures? So digital
forensics require a trained professional
with access to specialized tools and
environments. So organization must
decide whether to use internal teams
which has the faster response but also
incur higher cost. So maintaining these
uh specialized tool and specialized
teams incur higher cost. The other
option cost effective option is the
external vendors and contractors which
can be contacted or uh which can be
demanded on demand and they uh are of
lower cost because you needed need them
only when there is some incident not all
the time as your internal employees. So
forensic team should have expertise in
the networking protocols, the security
tools and platform, the system
administration and threat and
vulnerability management.
So forensic is a very high priority
activity. Therefore investigators must
have full organizational cooperation
cooperation in order to perform the
investigation.
What are what are some forensic tools?
So forensic tools may be either physical
tools or the software tools. So the
physical tools include the right
blockers
and the drive images. We are talking
about data drives or storage drives. So
these basically prevents alteration of
evidence while imaging the drive.
Alteration means they preserve the
integrity of data when collecting
evidence.
Faraday containers or faraday cages they
are in the form of bags or boxes which
blocks radio signals to prevent
tempering or uh our remote W. So if you
have some uh devices like let's suppose
smartphone or Wi-Fi router you can place
them in Faraday container so that there
is no external interference in the form
of radio signals. Similarly video or
audio recorders. So these log the
investigative process and maintain
evidence integrity and dedicated
forensic workstations. These are
isolated environments to avoid
contamination.
Then we have some software tools. So
these include the network traffic
analysis tool that capture and analyze
uh packets. Popular one is the
wireshark. Then we have the source
solution and the steam integration. So
the uh device the host or the server
where the incident took place they may
be integrated with the seam and we can
then use the data or the logs that were
ingested in team for the investigation.
Log analysis tools uh help in
reconstructing of event timeline using
seam or manual log import. Then we have
data recovery tools that restore the
deleted or overwritten files from disk
sectors. Virtual machines provide
sandbox environment for malware
analysis. So the are as we studied
standalone environment for testing the
malware analysis and other application
code analysis tool that revance engineer
or inspect binaries and decompile
software. Hing tools verify the data
integrity and chain of custody and
forensic tool keys are bundled utility
for example in case auto autopsy alert
kit and FTK. So these are specialist
forensic tools that have all the
utilities in the form of bundles and are
commercially available.
So what are some forensic techniques and
procedure and the first one is the
preparation. So we need to train the
investigators in standardized forensic
procedures and reference standards
include ISO 27041
up to 27043
and 27050.
Then we may use the SAS uh resources
such as Sans
cheat sheet and guides.
And lastly, the NIST,
excuse me, the NIST uh CFTT program that
it can be used for testing and
validating the forensic tools.
So common forensic processes include to
define the priorities. So the option we
can have to restore the operations
quickly, minimize the damage or preserve
the maximum evidence.
So we need to prioritize uh between
these either we can restore the
operation of organization quickly but in
this case uh we may lose most of the
evidence.
If you want to minimize the uh damage,
we need to quickly isolate the uh system
or power it off. But again, that will
compromise on the evidence collection or
we can uh if you are uh
greatly concerned about the
investigation on incident, we can
reserve the maximum evidence at the cost
of operations and the uh further damage.
Then we need to identify data sources.
So data sources uh may include logs, RAM
files, temporary files, system images
and we need to capture the volatile data
quickly. So the data in RAM in the log
files they are temporary and they need
to be captured quickly before the system
is turned off. logs if they are ingested
to the theme or if even if they are
stored on the system or the system
images they can be taken lately but the
temporary data they need to be captured
quickly
plan and collect data so prioritize
ephemeral and volatile sources as I said
the RAM and temporary file we need to
prioritize saving the data on these uh
locations and follow legal protocols
that include including warrants and
subpoenas if needed.
Then we have the document and preserve
the integrity. So maintain chain of
custody, timestamps and hash value.
Search for hidden or erased data. So use
recovery tools to uncover deleted or
hidden files and then perform analysis
which is to correlate data, reconstruct
events and reverse senior malware if
necessary.
forensic in the cloud. So what are some
challenges uh of doing the forensic
inside the cloud which is a specialized
infrastructure beyond your onremise or
traditional uh IoT infrastructure. So
the challenges include the virtual
machine mobility and multi-jurisdiction
issues and limited access due to shared
infrastructure. So unlike your own
onsite system, you do not have full
access to the whole host or to the uh
storage area network or to uh VM if you
are using let's suppose SAS solution. So
these are some of the challenges inside
cloud and solution include predefined
access rights in CSP contract. As I said
in the previous slide, while uh making
the contract with cloud service
provider, you need to include these uh
options in the contract that you may
have access to the data in the case of
need for the forensic investigation and
to use centralized loggings such as SEM
for visibility and leverage the CSA
cloud forensic model and Nest IR Nest
incident response 8006 guidelines.
Our next topic is forensic artifacts. So
these are digital traces left by user or
system activity based on low cards
exchange principle. So some common
artifact sources include
and the platform and then we have the
key evidence location that we can f
find. So in Windows we can look for the
windows event viewer logs the registry
recycle bin and hidden metadata where we
can find the evidence in Mac OS. We can
uh look inside the console logs, trash,
time machine backups,
list files or spotlight index. In Linux,
we should look for the user directory,
the temp war directories, system logs,
and caches. In browser, we should look
for the history of the browser, cookies,
cache files, and download records. In
local storage, we should look for the
file system metadata and removable media
traces. And in cloud storage,
it requires warrants or provider
cooperation
and uh we may like standard artifacts uh
that we have in other platform.
What are some network forensics? Network
forensic include the net flow analysis
which tracks the IP address flows, the
port address used by the traffic, the
protocol used and the traffic volume. So
these flows are basically provided by
the network devices such as switches or
the firewalls.
Then we have the packet capture or pcap
which captures packets for detailed
contact inspection.
Then you have the known bad traffic
which identifies communication with
command and control servers or spam
domains. And then the network devices
logs are valuable records from routers,
switches, firewall, VPN proxies and
firewall.
So how to deal with the mobile devices
or portable devices forensics? So
challenges of mobile devices include
strong default encryption. For example,
uh iOS or Android devices they have
their default encryption. Cloud
dependent app data. So some applications
send data directly to cloud such as the
iOS. So this is also a challenge to
retrieve or to uh analyze that data that
is stored inside the cloud. and the
remote w feature. So the mobile devices
they have these features. So if uh
utilized we may uh lose the key evidence
or data that is required in the
investigation. So the method of mobile
device forensic include to isolate
devices in parad cage as we said uh in
the previous slide to prevent the remote
interference to use MDM controls to
block the remote wipes. So the remote
wipes they are done through MDM that is
mobile device
management that is applied by the user
or you can say mainly the organization
to remotely wipe or lock the devices. So
we need to use these controls so that
the devices are not wiped remotely
through MDM and analyze device storage
application data and and synced cloud
content. So common connections of mobile
devices include the cellular
connectivity, Wi-Fi, Bluetooth and NFC.
And all of these connectivity require
separate specialized forensic tools.
So logging and monitoring activities. So
logging may be uh proactive and are
reactive or we have the combination of
both reactive and reactive. So proactive
logging is decide what to log, where to
store the logs and how often to review
these logs. Reactive log is when event
happens then logs are recorded and then
analyzed. Goal is to support map
effective uh security monitoring and
incident response. So the goal of log
monitoring and uh logging is to support
the security monitoring as well as the
incident response during an uh during an
incident.
So the log monitoring logging and
monitoring can be done through IDS and
IPS. IDS is intruding detection system
which detects suspicious activity and
logs it. It also sends alert. IPS
intrusion prevention system on the other
hand detects as well as blocks the
malicious activity. So the IPS when uh
it detects a malicious malicious
activity in can it can drop the traffic.
It can block the connection or stop the
services.
So we have these deployment models of
the IDS and IPS. We have networkbased
intrusion detection system and
networkbased intrusion prevention
system. So they are placed at the
network choke points such as the DMZ or
the VPN gateway and they monitor network
traffic for attack and malicious
traffic. Then we have the hostbased uh
intrusion detection and prevention
system. So they run directly on the
server or the workstation in the form of
agents or software and they monitors
individual host activity and file
integrity.
Then we have the EDR endpoint detection
and response. So these system combines
antimalware plus hostbased intruding
detection and prevention function and
they provides behavior monitoring and
response and they are endpoint focused
uh and they give endpoint visibility and
remediation.
So then we have the seam solution. So
what is seam? So seam is the central
logging then analysis of these logs and
alerting. So seam handles huge volumes
of log from multiple system. System may
be network devices, hosts, server and
all other application as well as
endpoints.
So these turns seem solution turn raw
logs into actionable security
intelligence and they help detect
incident faster and support talk that is
security operation center operations
seam functions and these function
include centralization which is
collecting logs from different server
endpoints, network devices, cloud and
apps. Basically all the system inside
organization they sends logs to one
centralized seam solution.
So this reduces complexity by storing
logs into a one secure location. Then we
have the normalization which converts
different log formats into a one
standard structure and this makes
searching through logs and correlating a
lot easier as compared to dealing with
all the different formats of logs that
are stored at different systems or
location. Then we have the function of
correlation and detection which means
analyzing patterns across multiple
systems that produces logs. So this
identifies uh help in identification of
normal user or normal normal not normal
rather than abnormal user or system
behavior
and it helps in detecting anomalies. For
example, when user log logs in into the
system during abnormal or or unusual
times such as during uh late night hours
or from unusual locations such as from
another country
and it also uses external data sources
such as threat intelligence and cloud
status for enrichment. Then we have the
function of alerting which is generating
alert and tickets for sock analyst. SK
is the security operation centers where
the uh theme solution is analyzed. Logs
from theme solution are analyzed and
displayed on screens and dashboard
and it provides continuous monitoring.
So these uh sock solution are
continuously moni monitor inside uh the
sock security operation center and it
helps security teams focus on
investigation instead of manual log
review. Our
next topic is the continuous monitoring.
So why do we need the continuous
monitoring? So the old model was point
in time audit. For example, ISO 27,01
FSMA or FSMA audit which was done once a
three year during a three-year cycle. It
means that only once a once in a three
year we conducted the audit and between
these three year there were no uh
mechanism for checking the uh efficiency
of the security control.
But nowadays the threats evolve too
quickly. So the out the results from
these audits of 3 years are basically
outdated. organization needed more
ongoing assurance rather than this
rather than this three-year cycle. So
continuous monitoring provides near
realtime visibility to the controls
effectiveness.
So key benefits of continuous
monitorings include faster detection of
control failures, better response to new
threats. It supports compliance against
the NIT NIST ISO and PCIDSS standards
and reduces the risk of undetected
security gaps.
So key components of continuous
monitoring includes the baselines which
is comparing system against standards
such as NIST 800-53
or the CIS benchmarks
and to prioritize higher risk controls
for more frequent checks.
Then we have the uh automation inside
continuous uh monitoring. We need to
have the automation component which is
done through the same solution endpoint
detection and response
user uh endpoint behavior analysis and
logs which helps in the real point real
time detection of malicious behavior or
security incidents. So automation
reduces manual workload and increases
accuracy.
So then uh the frequency component. So
not all controls are monitored
continuously. So frequency is based on
risk posed and the cost of monitoring
the security controls.
So metrics and action inside the
continuous monitoring. So good metrics
are for example the page deployment time
percent uh percent of systems meeting
security configurations and meanantime
to detect or respond to security
incident. Action plans include to define
threshold. For example, uh if the
patching as if the paging is uh less
than 75% we need to escalate the issue
and to clear response procedures when
matrix fall outside the limits.
So value and frameworks means monitor
monitoring ensures control remain cost
effective and it avoids spending on
controls that no longer reduce risk. So
key references to look for for
continuous monitoring are the framework
uh key framework include the NIST
SP800-137
which deal with the continuous
monitoring similarly risk risk man risk
management framework these are CDM and
ISO 27,04
so summary uh for the continuous
monitoring is that continuous monitoring
means ongoing assurance. So we need to
have the automation baselines and
metrics and these constitutes the base
or the you can say core pillars for the
continuous monitoring.
So you don't need to manually monitor
your uh security operation. You need to
have the automation. Then you need to
have some baseline or standard against
which to monitor your system. And then
you need to have some metrics such as
some percentage of threshold against
which you then you will have to escalate
the issue and these constitute the core
pillars of the continuous monitoring. So
continuous monitoring improves
visibility it improves the response time
and compliance against standard and it
is essential for modern security
operations.
So what is the egress monitoring? It
means egress or external monitoring or
you can say uh data going uh out of your
organization.
So egress monitoring prevents
unauthorized data leaving your
organization. So this detects data
excfiltration via different protocol
such as HTTP, FT, FT, FTP file transfer
protocol, email or through removable
media such as flash drive or portable
hard drive. So this includes both the
technical and physical controls. So for
example, data can be excfiltrated
through electronic email while it can be
physically exfiltrated through removable
media.
And a monitoring is critical for
stopping attackers from stealing
sensitive data either logically through
this protocol or physically.
So an important tool for egress
monitoring is DLP that is data loss
prevention tool. So this identifies
sensitive data using patterns,
signatures or reax and it monitors data
at rest that is data that is stored,
data in motion that is data that flows
inside the network and data in use, data
that is actively used by the host.
Functions of DLP include the first
function or the initial phase is
discovery where which is uh to locate
sensitive data on systems. Next we have
the monitoring phase where DLP track
file transfers, email attachments etc.
And then we have the response phase
where the DLP alerts require
confirmation and block the action.
So these are the key function of the DLP
solution.
So what are the ingress and egress
control? In egress or external control
are to block or monitor the outbound
data and it detect excfiltration hidden
in normal traffic for example port 80 of
the HTTP.
Ingress control prevent unwanted data
from entering the organization such as
rejecting emails with credit card
numbers.
Physical controls include to monitor
doors, docks,
fresh bins, removable media that leaves
the organization or enter the facility.
Our next topic is the log management.
What are some log management basics? So
these include uh basically the log
support continuous monitoring as we
studied the incident response and
forensic. So log are the basics of all
these activities
and frameworks such as ISO 27,01 NIST SP
800-53 and NIST SP800-92.
This deals with the log management and
goal is to collect relevant, accurate
and actionable events without
overwhelming the without overwhelming or
excessive data.
So what do we mean by uh auditable
events? Events that make sense that of
are that are important uh to log. So how
to define auditable events?
So why do we need to define these
auditable events? Because this prevents
too much or too little auditing. If you
log everything, it means you are logging
too much of data. And if you log too
much, it means you may be missing some
important uh log data. So key auditable
events are key events that require
auditing rude successful or failed login
and the access attempts access to
logging the system or access to uh
access to uh can say login or attempting
to access different host or devices.
privilege changes for example using the
command pseudo or the admin escalation
uh changes from normal user to uh admin
privileges security tool changes for
example disabling security tools such as
DLP antivirus antimmalware etc copy or
export of sensitive files or data
sensitive transaction in application so
all these events they are some events
that need to be audited or that need to
be logged.
So logs should include the user or the
process ID, the timestamps and it should
be standardized. For example, uh UTC
format, source, device IP or host name.
So the source that generated the log,
the device name, its IP address or the
host name, the object that was accessed,
for example, the file that was accessed
or the function that was carry carried
out and the triggering the policy or
event. So also the name of the policy or
event that was triggered during this
specific log.
So processing log data preserve
confidentiality, integrity and
availability. So use warm uh storage
ashing and separate log server or seam
solution to prevent tampering with logs.
So warm uh storage is write once read
many time. It means that you write only
once to that uh storage such as uh you
can say DVD disk that are warm disk and
then you cannot uh alter or change the
data. You can read data from it many
time but you can write data to it only
once. It means it preserve the uh
integrity of the log or the data.
Restrict access to authorized or
security staff only that have access to
these logs such as the sock analyst.
Plain storage capacity plus define log
retention period so that you do not run
out of your storage capacity and miss uh
important logs. Short retention should
be done on local servers and long
retention or archive storage should be
done on the same solution.
Our next topic is the threat
intelligence. So what is the threat
intelligence? So it is proactive
security activity. Threat intelligence
identifies threats, threat actors and
emerging attacks. So it complements page
management by detecting latent threats
before exploitation. It helps prevent
larger breaches through early detection
and response and it supports riskbased
decision making.
So what are some threat feeds and
sources? So types of threat feeds
include commercial vendors. So the
commercial vendor they provide APIs
dashboard and seam or sore integrations
mean alerts for example CESA Canadian
center for cyber security they also
provide different alerts and uh
information
industrial ISAX means sector specific
intelligence such as finance,
healthcare, retail and government all
these sector have specialized uh
information or You can say data
repository
and the threat intelligence can be
automated using seam or source solutions
so that we have the auto alerts auto
blocking up uh malicious IP addresses
and domain deploying the uh
vulnerability pages and isolating the
infected systems.
Threat huntings. So we have types and
methods of threat hunting. So threat
hunting levels include strategic which
which are high level risk such as uh
which uh you did for the cizo or the
fishing exposure. Then we have the
tactical level of hunting which are the
indicator of compromise from forensic
and operational which are attacker TTPs
that means tool technique and
procedures.
So where the threat hunters search? They
search in internal logs, network traffic
and endpoints. They search inside deep
web which is private but accessible uh
content and dark web through to or
hidden marketplace.
So the outcome is actionable
intelligence shared via seam to blog
conferences or ISAC feeds.
So user and entity behavior analytics
UEBA. So what is UVB? UEeba basically
analyzes users that is people and
entities that is devices, server and
processes on a network.
UBA uses machine learning plus
statistical models to learn that to
learn what is normal behavior and what
does uh how does it look like. So it
detects anomalies when behavior deviates
from the normal baseline and key purpose
of UEBA is to identify suspicious or
malicious activity that traditional
tools may miss.
So how user entity behavior analytic
works? So beh baseline behavior example
include for example LS usually logs into
at 10:00 a.m. and downloads 10 to 100 MB
of finance data uh finance data daily
maybe for generation of some reports or
other purposes. It includes her daily uh
task or her daily uh behavior.
So anomaly is when suddenly LS downloads
hundreds of GBs of data from legal and
R&D system and sends data externally. So
this is an abnormal behavior from this
normal baseline behavior.
So possible causes of this abnormal
behavior could include the account
compromised. For example, the LS account
may be compromised by an external hacker
or an insider
this actor.
Maybe there is some malware infection.
Maybe we may have we may have insider
threat. For example, Ellis may be doing
things on on her own maliciously.
Role change or legitimate unusual
activity. Maybe there is legitimate
requirement of this amount of data
download from this system. So user
entity behavior analytic flags this for
investigation or automated response.
So what are some benefits and responses
of EUBS? So why it is important? It is
important because it provides
individualized monitoring. So no one
sizefits all. It reduces false positive.
For example, Bob legitimately send large
files and it works with source seam and
IPS to automate the responses to these
alerts and incident. So possible
automated action include to quarantine
theffected or infected device via VLAN
to temporarily disable the user
credential or to trigger the deeper
investigation.
outcome is faster detection, limited
damage and better alignment with
organizational behavior pattern.
Our next topic is configuration
management. So configuration management
is a formal process to keep systems in a
known good and secure state.
It control changes to systems so
security posture is not unintentionally
weakened through misconfiguration or
unauthorized configuration. So
configuration items include systems,
endpoints and codes etc. Baseline is the
approved secure configuration of a
configuration item. For example, the
approved configuration of system or
endpoints.
Change management is the formal request,
review and approval of change before
altering a baseline. and change
management board basically review the
impact in the form of security cost or
operation of the change.
So what is the provisioning in
configuration management? Provisioning
is deploying system and application
according to approved baselines. It uses
scripts, golden images, virtualization
and infrastructure as code for automated
consistent deployment.
It reduces human error and speeds up
system rollout.
Then we have the asset inventory in
configuration management. So asset
inventory is that we must record all
hardware, software and cloud services
that are uh deployed. It uses proactive
control such as purchase system
integration and reactive control such as
system scans and cloud inventory and it
prevents unmanaged or unknown host
inside the organization also known as
the shadow IT.
So what is the baseline in the
configuration management? So baseline
the baselining define secure
configuration which is used to detect
the configuration drift. So we have a
specific set of baseline configuration
and if uh a system or a configuration
item has configuration uh that is does
not match this baseline we it means we
have the configuration drift and it can
be detected through this specific
baseline. Common sources of the
baselining include the dies
which is very strict. this benchmarks
which are best practices which is the
best practice and is widely uh widely
used in industry for baselining. Then we
also have the specific vendor guidance
such as from Microsoft, AWS and Apple
for their own system and applications.
So what is the automation and continuous
monitoring in configuration management?
So why automation is needed? Because
manual audits are too slow for modern
DevOps and agile environments and
misisconfiguration remain one of the top
causes of data breaches.
Automated configuration management
practices include immutable
infrastructure. So systems these systems
are not modified. They are built from
infrastructure as a code templates.
So cloud to such as AWS cloud formation,
Azure resource manager and terraform
etc. are the example of infrastructure
as a code. Continuous audits using
configuration manager SIM or sore and
vulnerability scanner.
File integrity monitoring uses file
hashes to detect unauthorized changes in
critical files. It is built into EDR and
host bed intruded
file integrity man tools.
So
what are the foundational security
operational concepts?
Apply foundational security operations
concepts and these concepts include
first one is need to know and lease
privilege. So need to know is when the
user can only access the information
that is required for their specific role
or project. For example, finance staff
do not need to access research project
data. Need to know supports
compartmentalization.
Next is the least privilege. Lease
privilege is that users are granted
minimum access necessary to perform
their duties. For example, data entry
data entry specialists should not have
admin rights. Implementation tips
include separate user and admin
accounts.
Use just in time access that is
temporary privilege escalation. So if a
user is performing 90% of the task that
do not required admin privilege. So
user account should be used for the 90%
of time and when admin access is
required the escalation to admin
privileges should be temporarily using
just in time access. Granular access
control in systems to avoid multiple
instances.
Next is separation of duties. So the
purpose of separation of duties is that
to reduce the insider threat, improve
data integrity and detect errors. Key
concepts include dual control where two
or more people must perform an action
together to perform that specific
process. 2% integrity. So no one can
access sensitive assets alone. For
example, encryption key scroll. An
example is for example a cashier and
manager both verify cash at the day end.
So this prevents single person fraud as
well as error.
Third foundational security operation
concept is privilege account management.
So privileged accounts are elevated
access users for example admin and super
user accounts and they pose higher risk
due to potential for misuse or attacks.
The best practices include provisioning
to include or do extra documentation
approvals and background checks before
granting privileged access.
use is to use the privilege access
temporarily using just in time access
and separate admin and non-admin
accounts and use mandatory MFA for admin
accounts. Monitoring is to do frequent
audits, log reviews, track accidental or
malicious usage. Deprovisioning is to
retain logs, suspend accounts instead of
deleting for compliance.
For example, I can key signing ceremony
requiring multiple users which is
adopted for remote work during COVID 19
while maintaining separation of duties.
Number four concept is the job rotation.
So benefit of job rotation include cross
trainining and resilience. So other
employees can cover duties. This means
that an organization is not dependent on
few or a single employee to perform
specific task. When the job is rotated,
other employee can do the cross
trainining and understand each other
task besides their own primary task.
Detect errors and mitigate insider
threats. So this reduces opportunity for
fraud. disrupts targeting by external
attackers using OS end or opensource
intelligence. So techniques for job
rotation is post vacations periodic
rotation of job responsibilities.
Number fifth is service level agreements
that is SLAs. So these are formal
agreement between the service provider
between the service acquirer such as the
organization and the service provider
such as the CSP cloud cloud service
provider or MSSP that is managed
security service provider detailing
expected service metrics
key points include service level
requirement SLR
which would be discrete and measurable
expectation for example 99% uptime
which means maximum 4 days downtime
during a year. Monitoring is to use
synthetic transactions, heartbeat checks
and response time tracking
and enforcement is legal agreement may
include financial penalties for unmet
objectives. Important of SLA is that it
is part of thirdparty risk management
and continuous monitoring.
So what do we mean by resource
protection in security operations? So
protect organizational assets that is
the assets confidentiality, integrity
and availability which is the CIA or
core principles of information security.
So media includes
paper, hard disk drives,
SSDs, USBs, cloud storage, etc. And
policies guided by standards and
regulation. And these standards and
regulation include ISO 27,01
8.83
which
uh talks about the media handling. Then
we have NIST SP800-53
which talks about media protection. And
then we have N SP800-88
which talks about media sanitization. So
these are the standards and regulation
that can be used for resource protection
or media protection inside organization.
So ensure policies account for industry
specific restriction for example banning
USB use.
So media protection and handling. So
classification include assigning
sensitivity labels that is internal,
confidential or public. So these
classification or these level should be
assigned to media so that they can be
handled as per these sensitivity level.
Labeling and marking is the labeling and
marking may be physical such as
watermark header and footer and label or
digital such as metadata file tags
storage cluster identifiers.
Handling guidelines include access based
on list privilege to train staff on
media procedures. For example, internal
use only drives must stay on premises.
They should not be let out of the
organization premises.
So what should be the how do we handle
the transport and disposal of media? So
protection techniques include physical
security such as logs, cables and
restricted access to the media,
encryption for the lost or stolen media
and inventory and periodic inspection.
Transport security include encrypt data
uh or you should use the self encrypting
media hash and verify data integrity on
the media. Secure transport means to
transport the media in logged cases and
to transport it through trained
couriers.
Sanitization and disposal include the re
reuse or destroy based on the need of
the media. So if the media let's suppose
contain very sensitive data, it is uh
best practice to destroy it rather than
reuse it. cryptographic eraser for full
disk encryption or cloud
storage.
So for cloud storage we cannot format or
delete the uhire
drives uh inside the cloud. So for that
we use the cryptographic erasure which
means to encrypt the data uh that is
available on the crowd storage and then
destroy the encryption keys. FDE is I
think not a full disk encryption.
Uh it is uh I will uh check this later.
I think it stands for something else.
And then we have the vendor managed
destruction which requires SLA and
security compliance.
Our next topic is the incident
management. So
we uh need to differentiate between the
event and incident. So event is any
observable system or user action such as
log to the system or the a file accessed
by a user. While on the other hand,
incident is unplanned event with adverse
impact requiring investigation and
remediation.
Examples include unexpected system
restart, ransomware attacks and extended
unplanned outages. So these are examples
of the incidents.
goal is to restore normal operations
quickly during incident and minimize
loss uh productivity or revenue to the
organization.
So incident management can be done
through modern tools such as sore
platform that automate the incident
detection and response. So not all
incident require security involvement.
Incident response planning is the
proactive framework to respond
effectively to different incidents. Key
components include to define the
incident types. So the incident may be
operational, security or emergencies.
Incident and response team structure
include the team include the coordinator
roles and uh roles and other
responsibility of the team member should
be defined.
Resources include seam solution,
intrusion detection system, checklist
and procedure documentation.
Life cycle process include detect, try,
respond, mitigate and recover. The
standards and framework that highlight
the incident response include ITIL, NIST
SP800-61,
ISO 27035,
ANISA,
CSR guide and isaka.
So incident response or IR life cycle.
So these are the step in the incident
response life cycle. So the typical
steps include detect, try, respond,
mitigation, recovery and lessons learn.
So we will go through all these steps
one by one.
So first we have the incident detection
and triage. So detection may be done
through automated alerts such as from
seams, different monitoring tools or
human observation.
And during detection we need to generate
incident report and begin the
documentation.
Then we have after detection we have the
triage which include determination the
criticality and crit categorization of
the incident and to allocate appropriate
incident response team and resources to
the incident.
Next is the prioritization which is to
use priority scores from P 0 to P5 based
on the impact and urgency of the
incident. So high priority incident may
trigger business continuity and disaster
recovery or additional organizational
plans.
Next step is the response in which we
gather evidence, investigate and follow
documented procedure. scenario- based
guidance for malware, breaches and
outages.
Then we have the mitigation. During this
step, we need to isolate or quarantine
the affected systems from the incident
and we need to contain the spread of the
incident. And to apply short-term fixes
and plan for long-term resolution.
Then we have the recovery. We need to
reso restore normal business operations
which may involve password resets,
system patching and activating business
continuity and disaster recovery.
And
next step is reporting. So reporting may
be internal which include team updates
and management reporting as well as the
external where we inform or report to
regulators, law enforcement, vendors and
public as per the requirement of the
regulations.
We also may have breach reporting which
include to notify the regulators and
affected individual as required by the
laws and regulations.
Next step is the remediation which
includes to address the root cause and
vulnerabilities that caused the incident
and to enhance policies, tools, training
and or stopping.
And I think this is the last step which
is the lesson learned. So conduct
postmortem or afteraction review
document improvements to prevent further
recurrence and assign action items with
accountability
preventative and detective controls
overview. So we have studied these
control uh multiple times once again. So
the security controls basically reduce
likelihood that is preventative or
detect incidents after they occur which
means they are detective. So cyst design
layer defense in depth to provide
proactive plus reactive protection. So
control must balance between cost and
asset value. Technology alone is not
enough. So people plus process plus
tuning all are essential. For example,
an organization Equifax breach cost the
organization $31 million in direct
payments. So this payment is far more
than the preventative controls that
would have required to prevent such
breach.
Effective operation of security control.
So tools like firewall intrusion
detection and prevention system seem
solution in AI based system required
correct configuration and continuous
tuning poorly tuned or ignored alert is
equal to delayed or missed in uh
incidents. So security teams must
collaborate with IT and network teams
for tool selection, configuration,
monitoring and alert management.
Communication is critical. So security
must support business needs not obstruct
them.
So firewall fundamentals. Our next topic
is uh firewall. So we are talking about
the effective operations of security
control. So these are different security
control and first one is the firewall.
The firewall basically control traffic
between network segments based on
different rules or security policies.
They help block unauthorized access
malicious request or control host level
communication.
Firewall are essential in zero trust
environments where no internal system is
implicitly trusted.
Firewall basically supports micro
segmentation by isolating workloads.
We have multiple types of firewalls such
as static or the stateless firewall.
These firewall are fast and they work on
simple rule checks but they struggle
with complex traffic. So these were
traditional legacy firewall. Modernday
firewall are stateful which tracks
session context
and they work better with protocols like
FTP but they also have higher overhead
higher overhead because because they
track session of they track uh keep
track of all the session
web application firewalls and API
gateways. So these protect web
application and APIs and they detect
attacks like SQL injection. Hostbased
firewall are and point specific rules.
They are basically deployed on a server
or a host itself. So these are they are
useful for micro segmentation.
Then we have the next generation
firewall or NGFW
which combines multiple functions such
as statepool filtering, intrusion
detection system, AI analytics and
threat intelligence.
Then we have the security groups such as
uh cloud which are used in cloud and
softwaredefined networking.
So these include virtualized firewall
functions. They are dynamic, scalable
and ideal for cloud deployments.
So in modern architecture firewall are
used for zero trust model which assumes
even internal user or system may be
compromised and they are not trusted.
The firewall plus security groups
enforce least privilege at every layer.
Micro segmentation isolates workloads
into small and controlled network zones.
They protects against insider attacks or
lateral movement after a breach.
Consistent enforcement across onprem
virtual and cloud environments.
Our next topic is intrusion detection
system versus intrusion prevention
system. So IDS or intrusionary detection
system detects abnormal or malicious
activity. It is passive means it only
alerts or generate logs. So it only
detects. On the other hand, intrusion
prevention system detects as well as
reacts. So IPS is active which means it
blocks or mitigate attacks
automatically.
So I IDs uh identifies
through known signatures abnormal
behavior versus the baseline. For
example, unusual volume of half open TCP
handshake means a sin flood or denial of
service attack is taking place.
So intrusion prevention system can take
action
such as automatically blocking the IP
addresses, inserting the firewall loose
rules are stopping the malicious
sessions. Risk
through IPS or risk that uh can result
when IPS is used include false positive
may block legitimate traffic which may
impact the availability. So when your
legitimate services or application are
blocked it means you have impacted the
availability of your system through
false positives.
So what are the intrusion detection and
prevention system deployment models? So
these uh include networkbased where the
IDS or IPS is placed at the perimeter or
key segments of the network and they see
network wired traffic but challenge uh
of this deployment model is that VM toVM
traffic may bypass physical switches. So
for example, if we have a server and we
have multiple VMs inside this server. So
the VM toVM traffic may not go through
the network.
That's why this traffic may be missed by
the networkbased intrusion detection and
prevention systems.
Then we have the hostbased intrusion and
detection and prevention system. So
these runs on individual servers or
hosts as well as endpoints. They detect
the local activity taking place on the
server, file changes and the system
misuse. They incur higher cost, resource
consumption and compatibility concerns.
So what are the white list and blacklist
also known as the allow and deny
controls.
So they are used for application IP
addresses, domains, devices and
countries. So all these may be included
in the white list or blacklist. Hello
list is where only approved items are
permitted. For example, only
organizationowned IP addresses are
allowed to access the cloud application.
On the other hand, deny list are
explicitly blocked nonbad sources.
example is to block traffic from
highrisk countries.
So these are implemented the uh white
list and blacklist they are implemented
through firewalls, VPNs, operating
system policies and email gateways. They
help reduce unauthorized access and
fishing exposure.
So what are the thirdparty security
services also known as MSSP that is
manage security service providers.
So why use MSSPS?
It is because of lower cost versus
in-house security operation center.
So
running in-house security operation
center is costly. Therefore,
organization nowadays use MSSPS
access to specialized expertise and
advanced tools. So, these MSSPS has
advanced tools as well as specialized
expertise scalability and continuous 27
2407 monitoring.
Some common SSP MSSP managed service
security managed security service
provider services include stock security
operation center which typically include
seam solution which may be full or
partial
DFI data digital forensic incident
response and MDR manage detection and
response threat intelligence field. So
these are some of the MSSPS.
So risk from MSSP or manage security
service provider include loss of control
over your sensitive data. MSSP become a
high value target for uh attackers. So
it this may result in supply chain risk
or this is a supply chain risk and so we
need strong contracts service level
agreements and data protection clauses.
Our next topics are sandboxing honey
parts and antimal anti-malware and
artificial intelligence and machine
learning. So sandboxing is isolated
environment for testing applications or
malware. It can be VM based or mobile
sandboxing for example iOS restrictions
or MDM containers.
Honeyods or honeyets are decoy systems
to detect unauthorized access. So this
must avoid entrapment
and must be used for passive
observation.
Entrament means to encourage someone uh
or lure someone towards unauthorized
access and unauthorized activity. So
alerts can be feed alerts from honey or
honey can be feed into seam or s
solutions.
Then we have the anti-malware and
endpoint detection and response. So
these may be signature based, heristic
and uh behavior detection based endpoint
detection and response ads host firewall
file integrity monitoring and user
entity behavior analytics. MDR combines
EDR with third-party analysis and
response.
Artificial intelligence and machine
learning tool. So they improve speed and
accuracy of detection. They require
large data set which may be a privacy
risk. Blackbox decision making may cause
may uh reduce transparency
and it is useful for emerging threats
and anomaly detection. Our next topic is
page and vulnerability management.
The software always contain bugs and
vulnerabilities. Security teams ensure
system stay updated and follow a secure
baseline.
So it requires coordination with the
asset inventory knowing what must be
paged and configuration management that
is updating baseline after changes.
Page management process include so page
is the software update fixing security
issues or bugs. So vendor release pages
regularly for example page Tuesday where
page are released on each Tuesday. The
core steps in page management process
include to detect vulnerability.
Then vendor publishes the page for that
vulnerability
and it should we check that whether this
page applies to the vulnerability inside
the system. Then we need to test the
page and then deploy and track the page
effect often with SLAs's and if there is
adverse effect of the page on the system
we need to roll back if required and
update the system baseline after
applying and testing and finally
confirming the page.
So CSPs and MSP may handle the patching
if organization is using CSP or MSPs and
SLAs's basically ensure timely
deployment of these pages. SLAs's with
MSPs and CSPs.
Our next topic is vulnerability
management. So the purpose of
vulnerability management is to identify
and reduce risk from vulnerabilities.
Activities during vulnerability
management include threat hunting which
is proactively seeking hidden threats,
vulnerability scanning through automated
detection of known issues, penetration
testing and bug bounties which are
humanled discovery of loss. Advanced
testing and automation include red
teaming which simulate real world
attacks against defenses. Blue team
basically defend the uh defends the
environment.
Thor automation runs the scans, opens,
deploys patches and speeds up
remediation.
So the purpose and process of change
management. So change management ensure
the organization moves safely from one
secure state to another without
disrupting operations.
Change change management works alongside
configuration management but focuses on
reviewing, approving and executing
changes. So change request includes the
purpose, justification and owner of the
change and then the resources needed for
the change to be carried out expected
impacts and the risk posed by the
change.
So change approval board or change
the change approval board and this is uh
change I think change core board or
something like that. So these are the
team or boards that review and approve
the changes inside organization. So
these boards basically review changes
for business value, security impact and
risk mitigation and after approval
change is implemented, tested,
documented and baseline is updated.
The type of changes include standard
changes which are low risk, predictable
and pre-approved.
For example, standard patches approved
software installations.
Then we have normal changes which follow
full change management process and
require change approval board approval.
And then we have the emergency changes
which are used during incidents or
urgent threats and they are implemented
immediately. So change approval board
can review uh change approval board
review can uh happen afterward
and it is streamlined to balance the
speed and security.
Our next topic is recovery planning and
key metrics. So the purpose of recovery
is to ensure availability of critical
data system and processes after
disruption. It is driven by business
impact analysis or BIA which sets
acceptable operating levels.
The core recovery metrics include RTO
which is recovery time objective is
maximum time to restore minimum services
after disruption.
RPO which is recovery point objective
which is the maximum tolerable data loss
due to the measured in time and MTD
maximum tolerable down time or maximum
allowed downtime which is time after
which the organization becomes non
viable. So important things to remember
is that recovery time objective must
always be less than maximum tolerable
down time. So RTO
is always less than MT.
So backup strate strategy essential. So
backups may be full differential and
incremental backup. So there should be
tradeoff between speed versus the
storage requirement versus the time to
restore from that specific backup.
So follow the 3 to1 backup rule where
which means that we should have three
copies of the backup. Two copies should
be local and one should be offsite
and ensure integrity
that is to test the restore processes
and confidentiality that is to encrypt
the backups and secure the old keys. So
why do we need two local? So two local
are needed and but these local backup
should be on different media and
different uh sources so that if one
media fails we have the another
type of backup from the second media
recovery sites resilience and high
availability.
So recovery site types
include the cold site which is the
cheapest where we have no equipment but
it also uh result in the slow west
recovery because you have no equipment.
When you want to use the cold side you
need to install all the equipment which
will result in longer times. Then we
have the warm side where we have some
type of equipment such as power
and the recovery speed is moderate. It
mean it is faster than this but slower
than this. So we have then hot side
which is fully equipped. So it is
fastest but also most expensive. So it
is faster than these two but also most
expensive. So this one is the the best
but also
lowest. Then we have the mirror site
which is fully synchronized and gives a
real time redundancy. It means that any
transaction at one site site A at the B
is mirrored in real time at site B. Then
we have the mobile site which is
portable and can be rapidly deployed at
any location.
So additional recovery and continuity
strategies include cloud backups and
cloud busting. So temporary cloud
infrastructure during outages.
Cloud busting means to use the temporary
cloud uh restoration and backups during
outages. Multiple processing sites so
redundant geographically separated
locations such as those deployed by the
cloud service providers
system resilience and availability. So
resilience is the ability to resist and
recover from failure
which include the automatic restart and
selfhealing.
High availability
or HA which is achieved through load
balancer
clustering and redundancy for continuous
service. Quality of service prioritizes
critical traffic and faultness where
system continues even if a component
fails such as in rates and redundant
power.
Our next topic is disaster recovery
overview and execution.
So what is the purpose of DR or disaster
recovery? So DR restores IT systems,
data and telecom services after a
disaster.
DR works with business continuity to
keep the business operating. It is
guided by business impact analysis
defined RTO's that is recovery time
objectives and RPOS's recovery point
objective to select technologies and
recovery methods. Remember the key
distinction between DR and BC is that DR
particularly especially deals with the
technology and IT system part of the
overall BCP or business continuity plan.
So you can say the BCP is the broader
plan and DR is you can say a subset of
this BCP and it basic basically deals
with the restoration of IT data and
telecom services.
Declaring a disaster. So disasters is
declared by authorized leadership when
normal operations cannot continue.
Declaring disaster can occur before,
during or after an incident, for
example, fire, weather event or cyber
attack. And once declared, DR plans
activates and shifts operations to
alternate system or sides.
What are some response sections during
DR or after DR declaration? So these
include life, health and safety. Our
personal always comes first. So this is
important point when we want to uh
recover or we want to safeguard the
organization processes the personal
safety of personal always comes first
and to follow to follow the pre-approved
action plans to avoid bad decision under
stress. So the DR plans are already uh
decided
and pre-approved. So we need to follow
these plans and steps in order to uh
avoid bad decisions during the actual
disaster where there is a stressful and
tension based situation. to ensure
coordinated response, clear roles and
complete documentation for insurance or
legal needs later.
Key personnels during disaster include
DR or business continuity disaster
recovery plans specify roles,
responsibilities and contact
information. So use cross trainining and
job rotation for redundancy
and it may include support for personal
and families such as uh if let's suppose
there is a disaster such as
environmental or natural disaster.
So it may also include support for the
personal families such as housing them,
transporting them to the to a safe
location as well as after their food
requirement.
crisis communication. So follow the one
voice principle which means only
designated spokesperson communicates
publicly. So internally the employees
managers such as including phone tree
alerts and internal sites are used for
the communication.
Externally we need to communicate with
the customer, partner, vendor, law
enforcement through press release or
notification.
So the disaster recovery includes
assessment and restoration. During
assessment, we identify the type, scope
and impact of the disaster. We
prioritize the recovery actions such as
including the evacuation of the
personnel, shutdown of the services and
relocation to the alternate sites.
Report findings to the management to
trigger appropriate
business continuity and disaster
recovery procedures. After recovery, we
need to conduct a post impact assessment
assessment of financial as well as the
operational impact.
Then we have the restoration. So DR
supports minimum operations. Restoration
returns to normal service levels to
restore operations to original or uh new
primary side after safety validation.
This includes logistic including moving
equipment, personnel and data action. So
security remains critical for
safeguarding assets during transition
and transportation
training and awareness. So personal
trained on safety, emergency actions and
assign DR roles. So regular business
continuity and disaster recovery drills,
evacuation drills, crossside training
and tabletop exercises.
This ensures faster, safer and more
coordinated response to disaster.
Lesson learned. So this is maybe the
final phase of the deer. It is conducted
post incident uh it is uh to conduct
post incident review
such as the postmodern uh postmortem or
afteraction report
during which we identify what worked,
what didn't work, what failed and what
needs to be improved to perform root
cause analysis to reduce the future risk
of such incident or disaster and update
BCDR plans using sides
test. We need to test the disaster
recovery plans before the actual
disaster. So why the DRP disaster
recovery plan testing matters? Testing
identify incorrect assumptions, outdated
information or flawed procedures. It
builds staff readiness. Rehearsed
response is equal to faster and safer
real world actions.
Testing provides assurance to
management, employees and customers.
Testing should start simple and increase
in complexity over time and every test
should produce lesson learn plus
updates.
So now going through some test types and
first one is the read through also known
as the plan review. So stakeholders
review the disaster recovery plan for
accuracy.
During read through we verify the
contacts procedures and assumptions. It
is least costly and done frequently
because it simply we are simply going
through the documentation of the DRP or
DR plan. So it is least costly because
no actual resources are involved
just to go through or read through the
document.
Next test type is the tabletop exercise
where stakeholders walk through roles
and decisions.
moderators guides scenarios and issues
documented
no operational disruptions. So here we
physically walk through different roles
and decisions but no actual uh
operational or no services are disrupted
during this you can say it is just type
of role emulation.
Number three is the walk through which
is simulation in place. During this uh
test type teams physically go to the
action locations for example the
alternate sides.
It validates logistics such as the
travel time to the alternate side and
the equipment availability and this test
identify realistic constraints affecting
the recovery time objective and recovery
point objective. Number fourth is
simulation. An example of this uh type
of test include the fire drill
evacuation and alternate facility
activation.
So the test coordination, communication
and actual response readiness. These are
tested during simulation.
It is moderate. During simulation we
have moderate operational disruption but
essential for safety.
Number fifth is the parallel test where
alternate systems run side by side with
the production system. So the alternate
facility and the primary facility they
run side by side in parallel. This type
of test validates backup system
alternate sides and data integrity.
It finds misisconfiguration that may be
missed by the previous simpler tests.
This incurs higher cost and it is
resource intensive because we are
running a complete production side
uh a complete alternate side along with
the actual production side
and last one is the full interruption
test. So this is the most actual or or
close to the reality and also the most
disruptive. So in this test the
production systems are shut down and
recovery processes are fully activated
as if actually the primary side uh is
struck by some disaster. This type of
test identifies all weaknesses in the
disaster recovery and business
continuity process and it is often done
on limited system due to risk and cost.
For example, power cut over test.
What is the security role in the
business continuity? So, security
responsibilities include to support
business continuity planning but are not
primary owner. So, the security
personnel are not the primary owner of
DC planning but they must support it.
They provide security requirements for
continuity operations. Premand alternate
controls when normal system fails. For
example, padlock if the power is lost to
the original you can say let's suppose
if there were biometric systems.
Identify updates needed in the business
continuity and disaster recovery plans
including staff processes. Lesson
learned
plan maintenance. So ensure updated BCDR
planes are distributed to all
stakeholder. Maintain offline copies for
availability during outages and remove
and destroy outdated plan versions.
The security
that should be ensured in business
continuity exercises and scenario
testing. The security in BC testing help
design realistic disaster scenarios. For
example, widespread ransomware,
determine when an incident escalates to
a disaster declaration, moderate
exercises, and answer technical and
security questions.
The key concept here is that security
incidents can trigger activation of
alternate facilities and procedures. Our
next topic is the physical security. So
what is the importance of physical
security? Physical security protects
system and data from unauthorized
physical access. Physical controls
change less frequently than logical
control. Renovations allow upgrades to
physical security structures. Physical
security requires coordination with
facilities, guards, and third party
staff. So defense in depth requires a
layered physical parameters for example
from public to building to the uh inside
rooms and physical access must
authenticate and authorize users just
like logical access.
So type of physical controls include so
we need to use multiple physical control
categories such as preventative or
preventive detrant detective
compensating corrective and
apply the physical control such as
fences barriers and as well as technical
such as badge readers and administrative
such as policy control
layered security ensures multiple
Checkpoints protecting the high value
assets.
So control selection depends on asset
value versus cost.
So what is CPTED principle? That is
crime prevention through environmental
design. So place restricted areas away
from the public and common employee
traffic. Use landscaping such as tree
water features to limit access without
fortress look. Use proper lighting to
data criminal behavior and plan window
placement to avoid easy breakins and
reinforce windows if required.
Marimeter and entry point security. So
public areas such as road and sidewalks
may require barriers and coordination
with local authorities.
Parking areas may use badge access and
surveillance.
Monitor utilities such as power, water
and telecom for tempering and use wide
angle or power tilt zoom cameras and
ensure clear lighting.
Ingress and eress point so reception and
guards check IDs, log visitors and
inspect materials. Physical controls
such as gates, turn styles, mantras and
polards. Sensors detect movement, heat
and pressure which are basically
physical intrusion detection systems.
Cameras and guards provide detr
detection and response.
External and internal facility control.
So external facilities include secure
backup generators, utility hookups with
fences and locks. This allow controlled
third party access for maintenance.
Maintain safety gear and fire control
near dangerous equipment. Landscaping
must support both aesthetics and
security.
Operational and internal areas of fire
detection and suppression includes
sprinklers, detectors and extinguishers.
Access controls for common versus
sensitive rooms. Enforce clean desk
screen and evacuation procedures. Ensure
lighting and surveillance coverage and
use proper building materials
including using full height walls and
reinforced doors.
So high security areas and data center
and server room. High security areas
include
uh include SCIFS,
evidence rooms and server rooms require
multi-layer access controls and
sometimes device restrictions may
include EMF shielded room that is
electromagnetic shielded rooms such as
parad cage. They are incur higher cost
but necessary for highly sensitive data.
Data center requires specialized
environmental and physical security,
strict access control with minimal
personnel allowed inside data center to
follow standard like ash ash r thermal
guidelines and uptime institute their
ratings
address personnel safety and security
concerns. So human safety, life, health
and safety are the top priority in
security programs. Security controls
must protect both personnel and
organizational assets.
For travel, provide extra insurance,
medical coverage and emergency
procedures for work travel. Use guards,
secure transport, translators, and local
guides in high-risk areas. Train
personnel on device security for work
and personal devices that is your own
device. Implement encryption VPNs are
dedicated travel devices wiped after
use.
Teach physical security practices for
laptops and devices outside the office.
Security awareness and training. So
awareness is informal, broad and
optional and it reinforces basic
security behavior. Training is job
specific, formal and builds proficiency
required skill and is tracked for
completion. Education is formal theory
based academic class and include
academic classes and certification such
as CIS. So keep call keep all the
content current to address evolving
threats and measure effectiveness via
test assignments or other metrics.
Emergency management coordination. So
work with first responders such as
responders from fire, medical and law
enforcement and drills communications.
So provide alternate channel if normal
system fail and share critical info
clearly. Business continuity and
disaster recovery execution ensure
emergency procedures are simple and
unambiguous.
Security practitioners guide the process
and ensure vital info is conveyed.
So duress duress occurs when someone is
forced to act against their will for
example through blackmail or when
someone is made postage.
So controls focus on preserving the
individual safety. Use subtle durous
signals, code words, electronic clock
codes or phrases.
Code should be discrete, rotate
regularly and include training for
high-risk personnel.
So that's all for this domain. I hope it
has been informative. I will also give
the link for the practice question of
the same domain in the video description
and uh like share and subscribe to the
channel and see you in the last domain
of this this Of course.